ever read that book 1001 movies to watch
before you die well this is not that the
following action titles all share a
dubious distinction
they each currently hold a 0 percent
rating on Rotten Tomatoes let's take a
look at some of the genres biggest ever
bombs before they blow X verses sever
likes this is probably what happens if
you ask actress Lucy Liu about the
disastrous 2002 film ballistic X versus
severed
[Music]
if you've ever heard of this stinker
it's probably because an astonishing 116
critics have branded it rotten in fact
it currently holds the record for the
most negative Rotten Tomatoes reviews of
all time
it's easy to see why Lucy Liu plays
sever a vengeful ex dia agent Antonio
Banderas portrays Jeremiah X a former
FBI tracker with amazing facial hair
together they wear form-fitting black
outfits blow things up and perform
martial arts that's pretty much it
we'll leave you with the film's best
line of dialogue
derailed is a disaster it's time to talk
about derailed we're taken to 681 to
Munich that's got a few things take that
I don't need you know do I want you not
the 2005 film derailed starring Jennifer
Aniston and Clive Owen nor the Korean
derailed from 2016 nor the Canadian
derailed from 2017 we're talking about
the real derailed the jean-claude van
damme derailed this spine-tingling 2002
opus features trains van Damme kicking
people and Van Damme kicking people on
trains
if disposable action movies had a face
it would undoubtedly be Van Dam's the
actor has a startling 20-year streak of
rotten films that started in 1988 and
wasn't broken until he poked fun at his
own public image with the meta action
satire JCVD in 2008 derailed is probably
the cake topper here but it's worth
noting that the 1999 adventure desert
heat and the 2001 head-scratcher the
order also have 0% scores
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a shame there was a time when the
public trusted the comedic stylings of
the Wayans family in living color was
fantastic and we hadn't been burned by
white chicks or a little man yet
Gokul ketki released in 1994
Keenan Ivory Wayans a low-down dirty
shame was the sketch stars attempt at an
action comedy which he wrote starred in
and directed the title alone invited
plenty of critical jabs and the
contrived writing and cliched fight
scenes resulted in Universal critical
failure oh and can we talk about the
offensive gay stereotypes Dee Bernard
homewrecker
he's with me I believe a dark tide is
deadly as a general rule of thumb sharks
just don't work on screen unless there's
a tornado or an astronaut is using it as
a reentry device
[Music]
but apparently the filmmakers behind the
2012 snoozefest dark tide didn't get
that memo
Halle Berry stars as Kate a professional
shark whisperer who clearly has a lot of
integrity someone was clearly angling
for another Oscar anyway
kate is intimidating ly knowledgeable
about all things shark she's beautiful
she's a he
how do you know it's a male I can see
his claspers on his anal fins in fact
you can tell she's definitely a shark
expert well sharks are really sensitive
snap so they can actually feel your
heart rate so they sense nervousness
running low on funds
Kate agrees to take a wealthy family on
a shark tour through a dangerous part of
the sea called shark alley you probably
know where this is going dark tide
pulled in less than half a million
dollars at the box office it isn't too
shocking considering you've already seen
the best part of the movie
precious cargo abort mission released in
2016
precious cargo is a film that's got it
all Bruce Willis actually it's just got
Bruce Willis damn straight
Willis plays the same character he
always plays a died in well Bruce Willis
type I don't make doesn't people steal
it's not good for business the beyond
generic thriller was universally panned
by critics
one reviewer aptly called the film just
another VOD craptacular
you're probably wondering if there's
anything we can recommend about precious
cargo nope